Hello, everybody.
Oh, wait.
Let me get chat in here.
Don't worry.
I decided to keep my repentance super chat here.
In case anyone wants to repent.
Since the new pope got elected or voted in.
Is that what it's called?
The new pope got voted in.
If you have any sins you would like me to forgive, it's right here.
But it's been a while.
It's been a while since we did a good night.
Oh, wait.
I want to... Okay, we're doing this live.
I actually, like, lay down in bed.
I lay down in bed in between streams.
I want to add something real quick.
Let me see.
It's all live.
Okay.
Let me see if I can find one.
Wait.
Okay.
Uh... What are they called?
Oh, that's what they're called.
Okay.
I know you guys are like, what is she doing right now?
Look, guys, you'll understand.
You'll understand when I find a PNG of...
Oh, wait.
That's so cute.
Okay, guys.
You'll understand when I find a PNG of it, guys.
You're gonna understand.
No, I have to log in.
Okay, never mind.
Okay.
I'm gonna steal this.
Yes.
All right.
You're gonna under...
No, Toki.
Don't steal it.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna snap.
You won't illegally download a card, would you?
That taught me everything I know because that was already illegal.
Oh, man.
I thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I know a lot of you are really confused with what I'm doing right now.
But don't worry.
I'm pulling up Photoshop.
It's another Photoshop adventure right now.
Can I send my repentance in advance?
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
What do you mean by that?
What are you gonna do later?
I'm doing something really silly.
I think it'd be really cute, though.
All right.
Let's see.
I'm doing something silly.
But, like, I think it'd be really cute if I...
If I Photoshop this correctly.
Oh, my God.
That stupid flower song is stuck in my goddamn head right now.
You can be my flower.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Ba-ba-da-da-da.
That stupid fucking song is stuck in my head.
Because of the YouTube shorts algorithm.
I'm gonna disappear for a little bit, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm still in your hearts.
Or I'm still living rent-free in your head.
Do not worry.
Let me do something silly real quick.
I'm doing it all live!
Yippee!
Don't worry, you're hearing my voice, so...
Na na na na na na, na na na na na na.
Na na na na na na na na.
Wait, why is it not...
No, that's not how I want it to work.
Sorry, I'm like...
K...
There you go.
All right, that works.
Wait, I can make it better.
Come on.
Stick it in.
Okay, there you go.
Yay!
It worked!
Oh, that's cute.
Okay.
Wait, does it work?
Does this work?
Okay, wait.
Looks weird.
Wait, give me a sec.
I thought it'd be a cute idea.
Okay, it sort of works.
All right.
I thought it was cute.
I thought it'd be cute.
Oh, Coyote, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, I must confess something.
Whenever you're Doki, I miss your feathers.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Next is thank you for the super chat.
All right, guys.
Now you can repent now.
This is the perfect time to start repenting.
This is...
You silly dragoons.
This is the reason why it's here.
It's time to repent.
Okay.
All right.
Look!
Yay!
See, it's like, it's like, you know, good night dragoons.
You know, I have a little, you know, a little good sleeping cap on.
Look at that!
I have a little sleeping cap on, guys.
I think maybe I should fix it.
Okay, wait.
Actually, give me a sec.
Maybe?
I don't know if I should put it in the back or should it be in the front a little bit.
Uh, Mr. Stan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I like to repent my sins.
As in the past two weeks, I think more about my new favorite game than my Oshidoki bird.
May I be forgiven?
No!
Unless you...
Unless you bribe me more.
I'm joking.
Mr. Stan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, Yabby, thank you for the super chat.
I like to repent my sins.
Uh, Forgizmas for trolling the waiting room with hallucinated loops.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Ultra noob, thank you for the super chat.
Forgive me, Doki.
Okay, uh...
I'm not reading it out.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Hello, Doki.
I like to repent for the impure thoughts I heard earlier.
You said some wild things.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That is why we have Goodnight Dragoons right after the Mario Mon stream.
That is exactly why.
Wow!
That was a good timing for you because I am feeling pretty EP today.
So I'm definitely gonna rest up.
I'm gonna rest up right after this stream.
Today's not gonna be a super long...
I mean, usually Goodnight Dragoons are not that long type of streams.
But today, I'm gonna make it...
How long are they usually are?
They're usually like an hour to two hours long.
I'm gonna speak a little softer today.
Because I don't wanna...
I don't wanna...
You know...
I don't wanna use too much of my...
I don't wanna be too overzealous today.
And too loud.
Cause I wanna rest up my voice.
I wanna take care of it a little bit more today.
So I'm gonna be talking a little more softer.
Um...
Just cause, you know, my voice is...
I'm pretty fucked right now.
My voice is pretty fucked up right now.
So...
I'm gonna be talking a little bit more softer today.
Cause it is...
CCC, goodnight time!
Wow!
Um...
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh...
Pardon the question, but did you ever get the desktop confessional working?
Um...
I haven't been able to go visit my local London Drugs recently.
Because, you know, with everything going on.
But whenever...
Whenever I'm able to, I'm definitely gonna...
Um...
The first thing I'm gonna buy is a desktop confessional.
So don't worry.
Um...
I sadly have not been able to go visit, uh, one lately to buy another desktop.
Cause I want, you know...
I wish I could use it whenever randomly on my stream.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Um...
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I have nothing to repent for my curses are fair and just for the drag goons.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your curses only made me stronger.
I ended up...
I just kept playing the game.
I...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
You make me lose more?
I play more.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
It only makes me stronger.
It makes me wanna play more.
To get back the lost RP I gained.
Ha ha ha ha!
It has failed.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
If your curses didn't work...
If your curse...
I mean...
If...
If you didn't curse me...
I could have ended it sooner.
Because I would have been like...
Oh, I got...
I got...
Celestia too!
On YouTube!
Guess I'll stop streaming!
For the day!
But instead...
Because I didn't win...
I...
You made me move to Twitch!
So I kept playing!
Ha ha ha ha!
It was your fault!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Um...
Emlinks!
Thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you thank you!
I repent not being...
Responsible for the money!
Too real!
Capable!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you thank you!
From my Laker!
Aw, thank you!
I really appreciate the support.
And you coming out of lyric mode to support me.
I really appreciate that.
Thank you again for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Fistful.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I miss repent because I can't make it for most of Goodnight Dragons today.
Thanks for the fun streams this week.
Of course, no problem.
I really appreciate it.
Um, yeah, I'm definitely gonna rest up tonight because I am feeling... I am feeling eepy at the moment.
And that's why I feel like a soft, dokey, soft, dokey time because I am feeling eepy and tired.
But I did promise you guys I'd be here.
They wish you a good night so you guys can finally sleep.
I mean, the last time you slept was three weeks ago.
Um, last time I told you guys good night was when I allowed you to sleep.
So, um, that's why I'm here today.
Ozzy, thank you for the magenta soup.
Ah, thank you.
Thank you.
It's my birthday tomorrow.
So, I guess this... it's a good time to repent for all my sins this year.
Oh!
I'll give you a happy, um, future birthday to you.
Just because usually I don't stream on Sunday.
Um, happy future birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Ozzy.
Yeah!
I hope you have a great birthday tomorrow.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, over.
Thank... welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I really appreciate it.
What time is it?
It's like...
9.35.
But like, you know...
Like I told you guys earlier, I've been, like, incredibly...
My energy is, like, extra low today.
Um, because, um...
I guess it's all been sapped out by rivals.
So, I'm already, like, super low energy today.
Uh, that's why I'm gonna head to bed super early.
Usually I don't sleep that early.
I mean, if ever.
Usually, usually we don't sleep this early.
But today's a special day.
Also, I realize there's no music play.
Um, there should be some music now.
Whoopsie.
It's been a while since we had Good Night, Dragoon.
Because I forgot about the music.
Wait, that's not the right music.
I was like...
Wait a minute.
That's not the right music.
That's...
That's the...
That's not...
Um...
Oh, yeah!
I would...
I forgot.
I would play...
I would play, like, lo-fi.
I forgot about that.
Sorry.
I just remembered what music I would play.
I was like, what music did I play?
I...
I was like...
It's been...
That's how long it's been.
Alright, let me grab some...
Let me grab some...
Let me grab some cute BGMs for us.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
I always need to remember the channel I use for it.
I use, like, a special BGM channel for these music.
For the music I pick.
Because...
Because it's cute!
Is this?
No.
Where is it?
Is it this one?
Uh...
No?
Where the fuck is it?
Oh my gosh.
You know when you're subscribed to too many channels?
And you don't...
I always don't remember...
The channel name.
Because it's, like, in Japanese.
So, like...
And obviously I can't read Japanese.
So, like, it's a struggle.
Alright.
Relax and everyday free.
Okay.
BGM free.
We'll use...
Oh, we'll use this one.
This one's cute.
Is it free?
It is.
Alright.
Ah!
Oh my god.
There's new music.
Nice.
Okay.
This is too loud.
Let me...
Okay.
Give me a sec.
It's too loud.
Let me...
Is this okay?
Is that...
Is that loud enough?
I don't want to be too loud, though.
So that you guys can still hear me.
Because I'm, like, not too loud today as well.
So...
Um...
I want to make sure that it's not too loud, too.
So you guys can still be able to hear me.
Uh...
GG!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Next.
I'm not...
Sometimes I can't read some things.
Ha ha ha!
Oh my god.
I can't read for some reason.
Forward.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I must repent.
I've been a fool inside an NBA.
And now part of my soul is trapped in a box in another dimension.
Part of it!
Oh!
You forgot.
I got Disney lawyers.
It's not just a part of it.
Uh...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I heard they're, like, making a new...
Speaking of Disney.
Um...
New additions to Disneyland.
Or Disney World.
Whatever.
Okay.
New additions to Disneyland.
Disneyland.
I heard about it.
What's new?
What land was it?
What's new at Disneyland?
Mickey Town Reimagining.
Lightning Names.
Oh!
Was it...
Francisco Square?
The Star Wars...
Okay.
That can't be right.
What are the new stuff they're adding?
Because, like...
They saw how good...
Um...
The new Universal Studios were gonna be.
So, they decided to add, like...
They were gonna add, like...
They recently announced new additions to the Disneyland attractions.
Because they got really jealous at, like, the opening of the new Universal Studios Park.
And, I mean, like...
I mean...
It's actually so impressive.
Um...
The universe...
The new...
Uh...
The new theme...
Themed lands in Universal.
Was it...
What is it called?
The...
Epic Universe?
Yeah.
Epic Universe.
God, I really wanna go to Epic Universe.
But the lines are fucking terrible now.
I would...
If I...
Um...
I would've...
Oh, man.
Honestly, if I knew about the Epic Universe stuff...
I would've paid so much...
To get the preview tickets...
I honestly would've...
Because I feel like...
Those were the only times...
To experience it...
Without the...
The stupid fucking...
Like...
Five hour queues.
I...
I can't...
Like...
I am not...
I don't know.
I think it's...
I think...
It's honestly too much...
To wait...
Three plus hours...
For one...
Five minute ride.
Like...
That's...
Even if like...
The queue system...
Is like...
Impressive...
And like...
You know...
They built like the...
Waiting queue room...
Or whatever the fuck...
Like...
It's called...
Like the...
You know...
The...
The queue up system...
And stuff...
Um...
And it's like...
It's just not worth it...
It's not fucking worth it...
To like...
Go through...
All of that...
Just to do a five minute ride...
And then you have to stand there too...
Like you have to stand and walk there...
I feel like getting the preview tickets is the best opportunity and you get to enjoy the queue-up system without the huge crowds pushing into you and bumping into you and crowding you up because I feel like when I saw some of the lines for it and everything,
like the queue-up system and stuff for it, I was like, oh my god, this looks beautiful at the Epic Universe, but it's just not gonna look the same when you're actually there, when it finally opens.
And I read testimonials of like, because the Epic Universe is open right now and people were saying that one of the rides, the ride's queue system was made to handle like, five-plus-hour lines.
That was how big the queue system was.
And it went to there.
Like, obviously, because it was like the grand opening.
So like, one of the rides was meant to have a five-hour queue system.
And like, I saw like, pictures of everyone lining up and it was just everybody like, bunched up together and I was like, oh my god.
That shit looks terrible.
That, that, that does not look fun at all.
And it's a five-minute ride, too.
I was like, bro, I, I can use, I can spend my time doing something else.
And like, um, I don't, it's like, I saw someone was like, oh, you could just do the VIP, uh, the VIP tour or whatever.
But like, I feel like, aren't like, VIP tours, you're taken to a different section?
And I feel like when you're taken to a different section, it's like, you miss out on what they built in the regular queue system.
Isn't that what, it's just, like, don't you just miss out on that?
Because you, you fast travel.
So like, I don't think that's worth it either.
Because you're just missing out on like, the actual thing they built while you're like, walking to the ride.
So, but, I, like, cause like, they usually like, have like, little cool easter eggs or like, um, uh, yeah, you can miss out stuff.
Cause like, that's why people build like, uh, that's why like, amusement parks build like, little easter eggs and, um, and, uh, little easter eggs and little like, uh, uh, nods to like, the game or the movie or whatever they're basing it off on.
And there's like, a lot of really cool things and all that.
But when you do like, the VIP tours or like, you know, Lightning Lane or whatever, you miss out on all of that.
And it's just like, you're paying more to see less of the cool things that, um, that you could see.
Um, and I just think that's like, I don't know.
I just don't think it's worth it.
Um, just cause like, just cause like, you know, part of the, um, because like, uh, they built such a cool, cool, like, queue thing.
It's just for you to, you know, look at it while you're waiting in line.
Um, the VIPs can see behind the scenes stuff.
Yeah, but then it's like, I want to see like, the, uh, the queue system though.
And, um, the waiting.
Yeah.
So like, cause like, you know, they, they purposely did that.
So like, you know, people won't complain as much just so you're like more immersed into the world and everything.
Um, Disney's waiting lines have progressively gotten worse.
I mean, there's more people.
People are making more kids.
Actually, no, that's not true.
I heard, I read an article that, um, I read an article that, um, apparently the newer generations are making less kids because everyone's like, we can't afford children, which is true.
Everyone's like, kids in this economy?
Are you crazy?
You were definitely, I gotta pay off my student loans first before I think about a child.
Just gonna get a dog.
Or a cat.
Just gonna get a dog and a cat.
It's like, it's like, two kids.
I, I, I, yeah, I recently read that.
Like, people were like, why the fuck are we thinking about children right now?
I need to pay off my mortgage.
I'm still renting.
I can't even afford my hobbies, let alone a child.
I can barely take care of myself, let alone a, oh my god.
And then, like, I remember talking about this before.
But, I read that babies can suddenly just die.
And, like, that's like a fear.
Like, I remember reading this, like, a couple of years ago.
And it's like, yeah, they can just die.
And you don't, because they just forget to stop breathing.
And I, I, the, that, that's always, that's like in my mind sometimes.
That I'm like, why would you just forget how to breathe?
Like, like, I, what?
Like, like, I'm just, like, so it's like, they're so, it's like, they're so fragile.
You just, you just don't remember how to breathe.
And I gotta make sure you breathe?
Like, I gotta, I gotta, I gotta, I gotta just make sure you're breathing?
Like, night and day?
Why are you so dumb?
Animal babies know how to breathe.
Why can't you breathe?
Like, that doesn't make sense.
Like, puppies won't just suddenly forget how to breathe?
They are just born this way.
Natural.
So, this is why, this is why.
Dude, they, we, we let all the non, we let all the non-breathing babies learn.
Like, we forced the non-breathing babies to breathe again.
And then.
We spooked them too much for the late games.
Baby animals know how to walk out of the womb.
Why can't you walk?
This is why.
Just let them not breathe.
Look.
David, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Since men is a ghost, you don't have to.
Oh my god.
This is why it goes into the repentance.
Sam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm an adult and I so forgot to once in a while.
Oh yeah.
All I'm saying is that, I don't understand.
Why do we, why can animals learn how to walk right off the bat?
And then you babies can't even walk out of the womb.
Sorry, I'm like shaking my hands as though I'm shaking the baby.
But then I forgot, if you shake the baby, it also just dies.
So.
Just let you.
Why, I can't even shake you.
Because you're so fragile.
Don't shake the baby.
Don't.
Do not shake the baby, guys.
Do not shake the baby.
So, yeah.
I don't understand why we let this happen.
Why do, I like saw someone was like, Yeah, but like animals live.
Animals don't live as long.
Oh yeah.
You know, I can name several animals that can live longer than us.
And can still...
And can still like walk the moment they are born.
Like, I don't know.
Several species of turtles.
Name every animal.
Literally, turtles exist.
Or tortoises too.
Yeah, but what about outside of captivity?
Okay.
AJB.
Yeah, I'm calling out your name.
You wanna be a wise guy, don't ya?
Well, you can say that all humans are technically within captivity.
Why else is our life span so fucking long?
You know what it was like back in the medieval ages?
You'd be dead by 30.
Just like those animals out there in the wild.
Do you know how much modern medicine has prolonged our life span?
If you were born in the industrial ages in London, you'd be lucky to live past six.
Because you're gonna be working in that fucking factory, little boy.
Making the clothes.
And you're gonna be missing fingers.
Child.
Child labor was legal back then.
You know what they did back then in the industrial ages?
They kept popping out children, because they're like, don't worry, if we have more kids, they'll earn more money in the factories for us.
No children yearn for the mines.
The consequences of the industrial revolution.
Anyway, anyway, back to super chat reading.
Some random pie, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh, I already read that.
Many wiener dogs are just as expensive as real children.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
But at least they won't disappoint me.
And they can't fight back.
Technically.
I don't have to be disappointed, and they can't fight back.
And they won't go through puberty, because they're neutered.
I don't have to deal with puberty, because I've neutered my dog.
Which you should, if you want a dog, if you want a dog to not go crazy.
Laffy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Why are you sure?
Psycho, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I am attracted to strong female VTubers.
Is this where I put my repentance here?
Don't worry, we don't judge or shame you.
You are forgiven.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Game, thank you for the super chat.
You know, now that I think about it, humans really are ironically made for a long time.
Not a good time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How did I get to this topic?
I was talking about fucking amusement parks.
How the fuck did I... Oh my god.
You know what's even more fucked up?
The fact that kangaroo embryos are built stronger than a fucking baby.
You know what a fucking kangaroo baby does?
When it pops out the womb?
It fucking crawls to the kangaroo pouch.
It has... Oh my god.
You know how tiny a kang... It's like... It's like a fucking embryo.
It's like a jelly bean.
The size of a jelly bean.
And it starts crawling to the pouch and like... And moving.
It shouldn't have any function as a kangaroo.
Um... It just crawls out of... Okay, let me show you the size.
I don't think any of you guys know the size of a kangaroo embryo.
I need a... Okay, kangaroo baby.
Like when it comes out of the fucking womb.
I don't think you guys understand.
I...
How do kangaroo babies get in the pouch?
I need you to understand how fucking... Okay, wait.
I don't know if I can show this on YouTube.
That's a little... That's a little gross.
And a picture of that is so... It's like a tiny jelly bean coming out of a hole.
Okay, I can't... I definitely cannot... No, there's like an illustration of like...
Exactly how small it is.
But even then, I know I can't show that on YouTube.
Dude, I'll... I'll give you guys the website.
And then you can see for yourself like the birth thing.
And how tiny it is.
It's like...
It's like an actual... Okay, jelly bean.
Okay, there has... Okay, let me find a more...
Safe for work.
No, wait.
Okay, I learned this from my...
I learned this from like an animal facts book.
So like, it had... It definitely had a very...
Safe for work picture.
Climbing into a pouch.
Alright, let's see.
Like, there's an illustration.
Um...
Oh my god.
I need like size.
I need like...
Illustration.
That showcases.
The size.
Of that fucking thing.
Alright, never mind.
I'll give you guys the website.
And you'll understand.
Alright.
Okay, and then you'll...
You'll see what I mean.
When I say it looks like a jelly bean.
Coming out of a hole.
It looks like a jelly bean.
Coming out.
33 days.
It took...
It's a 33...
Why?
And then our babies.
Our babies.
It takes like, what?
Nine months?
And you can't do anything with...
You can't like...
The baby can't do anything.
It can't crawl.
Why can't you climb like a baby kangaroo?
Why can't you...
That baby can't make any money.
Alright, but yeah.
So, um...
So yeah, I'm just saying...
Like...
I feel like all other babies...
All other babies...
In the animal kingdom...
Are built different...
Compared to ours.
Aren't...
Like...
The babies...
Um...
The babies for the human race...
Are useless.
And we have to wait until they're...
They're useless until college!
Why are they useless until college?
Fudge.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
On the bright side...
We don't have to have kids like female kiwis.
Or worse...
The female hyena.
But I know you guys wish they could be like...
The barnacle.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Amusement parks are captivity.
AJB.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nexi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Leto.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Have you heard the...
Video called...
10 hottest female Sonic characters?
It's true.
Okay.
Alright.
That's a reason why we have...
It's Repentance Day.
There's a reason why it's Repentance Day, guys.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Soren, thank you for the super chat.
Sarah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Soren, useless beyond college.
Are you okay?
Sarah, you wanna talk about it?
Are you okay, Sarah?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Whoa, whoa, that's a nice... that's something else to unpack here.
Oh yeah, anyway, back to like looking at... I'm gonna look at the...
Okay, what are the new rides coming to Disney?
What is this?
Uh...
First ever Coco ride.
Oh, that's gonna be exciting.
I'm looking for it.
I like Coco.
Coco... I love the music from Coco.
You know the song that he sings his grandma?
Oh my god, I cried so hard when I first watched Coco.
I remember like... Oh my god, the music.
I remember crying so hard.
Especially like Journey ending.
Oh, Trillton, Coco sings with his grandma.
Oh, I like that movie.
Coco was great.
Wait, when did Coco come out?
I was watched 2017.
That was 8 years ago.
Holy fuck, that was 8 years ago?
Oh my god.
Okay, like...
I feel like...
Yeah, wait, is it...
6 years?
Like 6 years?
Yeah.
That's old.
18, 19, 20, 21, 20, 23, 24...
Yeah, it was 8 years ago.
Sorry, now I feel old.
Yeah, I was watching a...
I was watching a clip recently.
Like an SNL clip where people were talking about like movies and stuff.
And they're like, oh yeah, like famous movies and everything.
And then like...
Um...
The host was like...
Look, here are all these famous movies of our generation.
Now name 5 recent movies.
5 movies that were made...
In the last 5 years.
And then it's...
And then like...
It was like really hard.
Because you're like...
5 famous movies within the last 5 years?
Because I feel like...
Recently, there's not been a lot of movies...
That are like...
Super classics, you know?
Like...
Um...
That are like actual classics that were like...
Everyone has seen type deal.
Um...
And everyone just named movies that were like...
You know...
2010...
And um...
2010 or like...
Below and stuff.
Because there's a more...
Remember movies that everyone would like...
Talk about and everything.
That like...
It was like more so like...
Everyone around the world...
Can like...
Remember and stuff like that.
I like how someone was like...
Mad Max.
But you know like the one that was like...
The...
Wait, when was that Mad Max movie?
Okay, do you know Mad Max Fury Road...
Was released in 2015, guys?
Or are you talking about Furiosa?
Because not everybody watched that.
Apparently Furiosa bombed.
Like...
But yeah, Mad Max Fury Road was 2015, guys.
And then...
And then like...
In the skit, they're like...
Oh, The Hangover.
That movie was released in 2009.
The Hangover was 2009.
Do you know...
It doesn't feel like a 2009 movie, doesn't it?
Like...
You would think about it.
Oh, yeah.
I love that.
The Hangover.
But that was...
10 plus years ago.
Stop.
What was it?
Oh, yeah.
But...
What was I was gonna say?
Oh, yeah.
But yeah.
Well...
How did I get to that topic, by the way?
How did I...
How did I get to that topic?
I want to talk about something else before that.
2009 was 16 years ago.
Oh, my God.
It says Sweet 16.
Oh, yeah.
Disney.
Disney, Disney, Disney, Disney.
I was looking up at the Disney Amusement Park.
But yeah.
I'm looking forward to Coco.
I'm looking forward to the Coco ride.
Sorry.
When I'm like tired and eatpy, I get more forgetful.
Because it's like...
I heard...
I got really worried.
Because I was like, oh, no.
Why am I like forgetting things?
Like, not forgetting things, but more so like...
My attention span is a lot lower right now.
But like, obviously, I'm eating stuff.
So like, my...
I get like a little bit more forgetful than usual.
Just because like...
Just because like, I am like a little more tired than usual.
And obviously, I'm a little more stressed because of everything that's going on.
So that's why I'm keeping like, oh, what was I talking about before?
I'm like, what was I talking about?
You know, wait.
When was the PS5?
I remember people were like, oh, man.
PS5 is so new.
But like, the PS5 was released like...
2020.
It's a four-year-old console already.
Jesus Christ.
It's a four-year-old console already?
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I'm a little cousin go.
The PS3?
That's such an old console.
My dad played it when he was a kid.
And that threw me off the guard.
It's not retro.
PS1 is retro.
PS2 kind of.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Beep beeps.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
This is your usual Yaptopic hopping style.
And we love you for it.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
And we still don't have games on it.
We still don't have games on the PS5.
It's four years old.
It should be able to walk now.
It should be able to say, Mama, Papa.
But yet, we don't have games on the PS5.
Wait, how many games does the PS5 have?
Wait, how does it have 3,503 games?
What are they?
What are the 3,000 plus games?
How many?
They're all PS4 games.
Jokey.
They're all...
Alright.
How many exclusive games does the PS5 have?
Has a substantial library of exclusive games.
Alright.
How many are they?
48?
Out of 40...
That's like 10 games...
Alright, 10 games a year.
None of these are...
Okay, that's 10 games a year.
I mean, it's not...
I guess...
I mean...
A whopping 48.
I mean, I guess they just make 10 games a year.
But how many of them are good games?
What the fuck is Feed My Raptor?
What?
They made a sequel to it?
Wait.
What is this game?
Feed My Raptor.
A PS5 exclusive.
What did I do?
And they made a sequel.
I'm fucking...
I'm watching this game.
Feed My...
It's 2 minutes long.
This is not a game.
What do you mean?
What is this game?
Guys, this is one of the exclusives on the PS5.
And it's called...
And it's 2 minutes long.
And it's just like...
Feed...
That's the game.
And there is a sequel.
You're just feeding...
What the fuck is Feed My Raptor 2?
What is this?
It's one...
Why would you pay for this?
Why?
What the fuck?
Why is it?
You know what?
What do I...
That's a good idea.
I'm gonna...
Okay.
I'm gonna write that down.
Re...
Stream...
Feed...
My Raptor.
I see why there's only 48.
They made a sequel to Feed My Raptor.
There's a sequel.
There's...
How many views?
That video I just...
You...
That video I just linked you had 300 views.
And it was...
Oh my god.
That guy's gonna be like...
Why is there so many people suddenly watching my Feed My Raptor tutorial on how they kept...
Man, so many people suddenly wanna get the trophy for Feed My Raptor.
I wonder why.
I...
I wonder why so many people wanted to feed their...
Play Feed My Raptor today.
The hit game.
Guys, that's...
This is a PS5 exclusive, by the way.
Feed My Raptor.
And the very hyped, enjoyable Feed My Raptor 2.
Coming to your local theaters.
When will we get Feed My Raptor 3?
When?
That's what I'm talking about.
I've been waiting 20 years for Feed My Raptor 3.
Let's see.
Oh yeah, there's Death Stranding 2 on the...
On the...
Oh, I can't...
They have to make the new Kingdom Hearts game in a PS5 exclusive, right?
Which might not be released ever.
Because like...
I'm just wondering.
Are they gonna...
Are they gonna recast Sora?
Like, I'm just...
I'm...
Um...
I'm wondering...
Hmm...
What's gonna happen with the Sora situation?
I'm just...
Like...
That's like...
The question here.
Is it...
They didn't...
They didn't say anything.
What happened with Sora?
The guy who voice asked Sora got arrested.
And...
So...
And so like...
Um...
Because it was like...
Apparently...
It was like...
He was like...
Like his home burned down or something.
So he went on like a psychotic...
Like...
What was it called?
When...
Um...
A psychotic mental break.
From it.
Yeah.
And he got like really drunk.
And like...
Uh...
You know...
Really messed...
Like...
Yeah.
And he's like going through it right now.
But then it all got recorded.
It...
Yeah.
He had a mental breakdown.
And it all got recorded.
And he said...
He said some things.
So like...
I'm like...
Wait...
What's gonna...
What's gonna happen to Kingdom Hearts 4 after that?
Like...
I was like...
Yeah.
So like...
There has been like...
No...
Nothing related to it.
There's been...
Uh...
Nothing related to it.
But like...
It's still...
You're just...
Everyone's like...
What's gonna happen?
Like...
And it's all like...
Up in the air.
But we have...
We also like...
Haven't had any...
Uh...
We also have...
Haven't had any like...
Updates recently...
On Kingdom Hearts 4...
In a very, very long time.
So we don't know...
Um...
We don't...
Like...
We don't know what's gonna happen.
And I feel like...
Honestly...
With the raid...
I just hope...
If Kingdom Hearts 4...
Like...
Whatever they're gonna do...
What are they gonna do with Sora?
I do hope they don't...
Rush anything...
They don't rush anything...
Because Kingdom Hearts 3...
Fucking sucked.
I think we all know...
I literally...
I told you guys...
I stopped playing Kingdom Hearts 3...
After like...
Two worlds.
After I got to the Elsa world...
I was so fucking bored.
Like...
I...
I just...
No, I didn't enjoy it.
But...
And even then...
It took them so long to develop.
I'm like...
Kingdom Hearts...
Uh...
2...
Was released on...
2005...
And Kingdom Hearts 3...
Uh...
Was released in 2019.
And even then...
I was like...
I...
I don't know.
Maybe it's because the story...
I...
I didn't like it.
I know some people are like...
Oh, I like it.
But like for me...
I...
I feel like...
Uh...
I feel like for me...
I just didn't enjoy Kingdom Hearts 3 anymore.
I just felt...
The story for me...
And like...
How it progressed was like...
Not as good.
Uh...
Not as good as, like, Kingdom Hearts 1 and 2, and it was... I just felt like... It felt... I don't know.
People were saying it was because it got rushed, so I hope they, like... They, like, fixed the issues for it.
Um, and then I didn't even, like... I didn't even... I couldn't even keep playing at that point.
I just looked up screenshots of what the other worlds were.
But it was just... Maybe it's because, like... What worlds did they choose, anyway?
Worlds.
What worlds did they choose?
They chose Frozen, Monster Inc.
Uh, Big Hero 6.
Okay, what were the worlds in Kingdom Hearts 3?
Uh, Toy Story.
Um, thank you for the raid, Hanta.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I'm just gonna do and say it.
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho!
Dude, is that your confession for today?
Thank you for the super chat, T-Dragon.
Thank you, thank you.
Next seat.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Uh, Joki, there were, like, five Kingdom Hearts games between two and three.
They didn't start development on three for ages.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, there's so many.
That's why I also didn't, like...
There were, like, a million spinoffs that told, like, a million side stories of everything.
And then you're supposed to, like, know what the fuck was happening in these side stories going in to Kingdom Hearts 3.
And then, like, it made me even more confused with what the fuck was going on.
Because I quit... I... Obviously, I didn't play all the side story games that...
That was going on.
And there was, like, extra plot in, like, the mobile games and everything.
And, like... Because, like, I didn't... I didn't... I didn't, like...
Obviously, I didn't play all of them in between.
I think the one I remember playing the cards one...
Oh, my God!
Yes!
There was, like, one!
I remember in Kingdom Hearts 2...
Okay, they started doing this in between Kingdom Hearts 1 and Kingdom Hearts 2.
Where, like, you know how, like, Zora forgets all his memories?
And he gets into a fucking pod?
And then... But then... And then Kingdom Hearts 2, you're, like...
You know, you're Roxas.
And you're just, like, wait...
And then I remember as a little kid, I was, like, why is he in the pod?
And then you're supposed to play Chain of Memories in between?
You're supposed to play Chain of Memories to figure out what was...
That led to how he gets into the pod.
But they only did that...
Like, they did one of that, you know?
It was just one of that moment that happened.
So that explains why he's in the giant white pod and everything.
Wait, was it released after?
I don't remember.
I was just, like, why is he in that thing?
I was so confused.
I thought it was, like, before.
No, it wasn't.
No, it was in between, wasn't it?
I thought it was in...
Yeah, it was before.
Yeah.
And it was a GBA game.
Yeah, it was a Game Boy Advance game.
And you're supposed to play the Game Boy Advance game to know what the fuck to progress into Kingdom Hearts 2.
And it explains everything as to why he was trapped in this fucking white pod.
But, like, obviously, in Kingdom Hearts 2, when you're playing it, you wouldn't know that.
Because, like, you're too busy being like, ooh, Roxas Axel.
You know?
You wouldn't, like, the Roxas Axel distracts you from the fact that you're missing, like, this entire plotline of how he got into that pod.
You're like, because you...
Because you're just like, yay, Roxas!
So, like, I didn't, like, realize, like, I, like, ignored the whole thing of why, like, Sora was there and how Rox is, and, like, why Sora was there and everything.
And then, obviously, I got to play Chain of Memories.
Like, later on, they re-released Chain of Memories.
They re-made Chain of Memories into, yeah, that was my jingle jangle that they did to me.
But they released Chain of Memories, um, uh, re-made it into, like, the PlayStation 2, or was it, yeah, to the PlayStation 2 and, like, re-made it for PlayStation 2.
Or was it PlayStation 3?
I don't remember.
It was so long ago.
They made a console version of it.
And that's when, when I played it, I was like, oh my god, was that what's happening?
I was like, I was like, wait a minute.
That's why I was trapped?
Like, I was like, this, all of the, I was supposed to know all of this going in?
Like, oh no, don't worry.
I played that one.
I don't worry.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I definitely played that one.
Um, Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
These are the spinoffs I played.
I played 358 slash 2 days and Chain of Memories on the console.
Those were the two spinoffs I played.
But apparently, there's a million more that I missed out on.
Like, Birth by Sleep.
Like, I did not play Birth by Sleep.
Um, so like, that confused me as well.
Because that talks about the Keyblade Wars, right?
That was where the Keyblade Wars was supposed to be.
And that explains more about it.
And about, like, Xehanort?
I don't...
Organization 13?
Explains Organization 13?
And, um, yeah.
So like, I didn't play that one.
Because it was, um...
Oh no, the Keyblade Wars was a mobile game?
Jesus Christ, I...
This is why the creator of Kingdom Hearts have to look up recap videos whenever he develops a new Kingdom Hearts.
Um, no, not the Organization 13.
It was the...
The guys before they became nobodies.
Oh my god, this is so confusing.
Because they...
They show up.
Um...
Before they became nobodies.
They're in that game.
And, like...
It talks about their backstories.
And how all of them are technically connected.
And how that came to be.
And then...
Oh my god.
Also, by the way, if you guys didn't know...
The creator and writer of Kingdom Hearts...
Fucking has to look up recap videos...
Of other YouTubers...
Connecting everything.
Because even he doesn't fucking remember.
Because it's so complicated.
He doesn't even remember what the fuck is going on.
But he made so many games...
On different consoles...
And mobile games...
That explain the plot.
And you have to buy them on different platforms...
To understand what the fuck is going on.
And I think in Kingdom Hearts 3...
I was so confused.
Because I was like...
What the fuck is that...
I was like...
Why...
Oh my god.
I got so confused in Kingdom Hearts 3.
Like, it started getting really confusing.
I...
And then that's why I wasn't into the story...
Anymore...
Like...
It can...
Yeah, it continues...
Apparently, it continues...
Plot points...
From a mobile game...
That wasn't even finished...
And I was like...
I was supposed to know that?
I was supposed to know all of that?
Like...
I just want to be a funny...
Final...
I just want to be a funny anime boy...
In the Disneyland world...
I just...
I don't know what I'm doing...
I...
At least...
What are these original characters...
Doing in my anime Disney game?
Get them out of here!
Put more Final Fantasy characters in here...
If you want anime characters!
Get these original characters...
Out of my way!
I'm just here for my...
Disney characters...
My...
Disney characters!
Um...
Zyko...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
I still have Kingdom Hearts 3.
You're getting disgruntled in the backlog corner...
Because I'm lazy to go through all the recap videos!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Thorn came!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Ha ha ha ha!
But Donald, you see the player!
Guys, I don't need more original characters...
In my Kingdom Hearts game!
I'm barely like...
The last...
Okay, I would say...
I would say...
That...
I would say that...
Organization 13...
Were good OCs that he's created...
But then it all went downhill...
They all went...
Ha ha ha!
I...
I don't know any other good OCs that he made after that...
After the other OC inserts that he made...
I...
Not even...
Okay!
But because there were 13 of them...
Like...
Only one...
They had one for every flavor...
You know?
Like...
For like...
You know...
If you were like a particular character archetype thing...
Um...
A particular character archetype that you liked...
Then like...
There's one for you in Organization 13...
You know?
Like...
There's like...
Oh, I like this type of person...
And then they like...
Obviously it's like one for each per...
Like...
One for each person...
You know?
Ha ha ha ha!
So maybe like...
You know...
Oh man...
I hate this type...
But I like that other...
I like hate this member...
But I like...
The other member...
And then...
And then you'd be like...
But then someone else would be like...
How dare you?
I like this member...
And hate your member...
And I like how someone was like...
Aqua was good...
Yes, because there's barely any female OCs in Kingdom Hearts.
Of course, in a C, there's barely any female OCs that he inputted in Kingdom Hearts.
Like, you just take what you can get.
If you think about it, it's the worst.
You're right.
There's Xeon crying.
And they... Okay, also, I just realized there's like...
And it's all, like, Kairi recolored.
It's like, Kairi in different recolored different colors.
Like, pick a new hairstyle.
Why are they all the same hairstyle?
It's like, and then you're like, that's not true.
We have Namin.
Namin is just Kairi, but her hair is slightly longer.
And she's blonde.
They're all just different colors of Kairi.
For real.
We've got blonde, black hair, and blue hair.
And then if you want the original...
It's just...
They're just all recolored versions of hair.
Like...
You can't say it.
You know I'm right.
And then if you think about it, the only woman in Organization 13 is just...
Also, you could say it's just her.
But, like, she's a bad girl.
You could technically...
Could be like...
Like...
What's her name?
Larxene?
Is that...
That's her name, right?
Okay.
Yeah, but it's almost the same.
If you realize if her hair was not slicked back, it's the same hairstyle.
She's just older.
And her hair is slicked back.
But if you realize her hair...
If you realize when her hair isn't slicked back, it's literally the same hairstyle.
And then she...
Kairi...
He is...
Um...
It's still...
Alright.
Okay.
Sorry.
I just need to get that out here for those who are in...
I just...
I...
That was like an epiphany for me.
I was just like, wait, there's barely...
Barely...
There's like, you don't have much choice here.
There's not a lot of choices for the female OCs in Kingdom Hearts.
Um...
He finally released your...
It's like, oh yeah, but I wanna...
There's literally only one, like, the bad girl, and that's her.
The ranting is real.
I guess like, if you want more...
I guess like, what the mode...
The gacha game had more female characters, but then you have to play the Kingdom Hearts gacha game.
That shut down.
If you wanted more pickings.
The many sides of Kairi.
Oh, sorry.
I got really passionate there.
I actually really liked Kingdom Hearts 1 and 2 growing up.
I was just very disappointed that Kingdom Hearts 3 was fucking terrible.
I was so disappointed in that.
Like, that was just the rage that built up inside me.
How bad they handled it.
Because I had to know a million things.
It's like...
It's like Marvel.
Um...
I feel like...
I don't watch Marvel movies.
Generally.
Because I said like, I'm not really into Marvel...
The Marvel Cinematic Universe.
But I heard that...
Um...
I heard that like, in the current Marvel Cinematic Universe, people are not really like...
That into...
They're not really into the Marvel Cinematic Universe anymore.
And like, apparently the CEO that handles the MCU...
Or like...
What do you say called CEO?
The director for...
Like, the guy...
The main guy that handles the MCU.
Is like...
Saying that there's an issue right now.
And it's that...
It's so bloated.
Where...
Where like...
You have to...
To understand the newer movies.
You have to understand...
The 20 plus years...
Of lore.
That they built into it.
To understand the newer movies.
And if you like...
Miss out on something.
And they're all like...
On like Disney Plus.
Or like on TV shows.
Right?
And it's like...
Some of them is like...
Plot within TV shows too.
So it's like...
It...
It gets really rough.
Because you have to watch...
A TV show.
From beginning to end.
To like...
Understand...
What the fuck is going on.
In some of the newer movies.
And now I'm like...
I...
It's just hard for newer viewers.
To get into.
To...
Because if you're like...
A newer viewer.
That wants to get into like...
The...
Marvel Cinematic Universe.
You have to watch...
A bunch of like...
Stuff that happened before then.
To go straight into a new...
Marvel movie.
To understand...
The context of what's going on.
It's hard to just like...
Watch the movie.
And realize what the fuck is happening.
If you didn't watch...
What the fuck was happening...
Before then.
On like...
The TV shows.
Or like...
The movies.
To figure out...
Where it's progressing.
Or like...
And they'll introduce like...
Characters.
That might have shown up.
In the TV show.
And you're like...
Who's that?
You're like...
Oh that guy?
And you're like...
Who's that?
Why are they treating it...
As if I know who he is?
And you're like...
Oh yeah.
That guy?
He had his own show.
On Disney Plus.
And he was like...
A really well liked character there.
And that's why he got promoted to the movie, because it's very important to the plotline, too.
And you're just like, okay, so he just shows up as if I know who he is?
Because I remember... I don't remember which movie it was that I watched.
I remember, like, I tried to watch some of the newer movies that are out.
And I was like, who the fuck is that guy?
And then... and I'm just so confused.
And I googled him?
Because they don't... it's like he's there as if he's always there.
So, like, I didn't understand.
And they had to google it.
And they're like, oh, yeah, his first appearance is in this TV show.
And I was like, what the...
If I have to Wikipedia your character...
Because if I have to Wikipedia slash...
I don't know...
Adgrok, who is he?
Adgrok, who is this character in the movie?
Then that's a problem for me.
That's a huge problem.
So...
Is this true?
Is this real?
Adgrok, where is this movie from?
Wait, what movie is this?
Adgrok.
Don't speak his name.
Don't worry.
I don't use...
Guys, okay.
Um...
I don't use Grok, but I'm...
Okay, if you're in the member stream, you'll realize how much I fucking hate the Adgrok shit.
Because, like, I can't get real answers anymore on Twitter.
Everybody just does, like, Adgrok.
Is this real?
Adgrok.
Where is this from?
There's, like...
Nobody gives you replies anymore.
I remember if I don't know where something is from, or if somebody is explaining context...
A real person will explain it to me.
Or, like, tell me where it's from.
But now, everybody is using Adgrok.
And sometimes, it's not even accurate.
It tells me something so different.
And I'm tired.
I'm so tired.
It's just all Adgrok.
I need to know where is this clip from?
Please tell me.
Ad chat.
Is this real?
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm tired of this, Grandpa.
Yeah.
Also, like, speaking of AI.
I don't know if anybody saw this article that popped up that went viral about how...
I know I talked about this in members about, like, using AI for college.
And there was, like, uh...
And right after I had that discussion in the member stream, um...
I saw a Twitter...
A viral Twitter thread of, like, um...
A viral, like, art...
Like, a viral Twitter article about, like, how more and more...
Different students are now using AI, even in Ivy League, to do their assignments.
It was crazy.
There was, like...
Okay, they got this, like, statement from a student.
And, like...
Okay, I was, like...
Um...
I was, like...
X for doubt.
Because this student...
Okay, this student was, like...
I'll read this article to you.
Because I, like, saved it.
Because I was, like, what the fuck?
Like, there's no...
You did something.
So, like...
It was, like...
Basically...
Okay, let me read this.
Uh...
Lee stepped into Columbia University campus this past fall.
Columbia, I believe, is an Ivy League.
Uh...
By his own admission, proceeded to use generative artificial intelligence to cheat on nearly every assignment.
As a computer science major, he depended on AI for his programming classes.
I just dumped the prompt into ChatGPT and handed in whatever it, um...
Spat out.
AI wrote 80% of every essay he turned in.
I'm just, like...
Jesus Christ.
Bro, you're in Columbia University.
Like...
Oh, my God.
And he was, like...
Yeah...
I got accepted into Harvard early.
But then...
The university resigned his offer.
Because he said...
He got suspended for sneaking out during the overnight field trip before graduation.
And a year later, he tried to apply to 26 schools.
But he got rejected in all of them.
So, I was, like...
What did he do?
What did he actually do?
There's no way.
There's...
He did something.
There's no way.
You sneaked out during a field trip.
And then Harvard was, like...
No, no, no.
No bad boys in my university.
Sneaking out during a field trip?
That's a bad boy thing to do.
Harvard students have done way more fucked up shit than that.
While they're in Harvard.
And they're still in Harvard.
And...
That's like...
He...
Did something.
Wasn't there a thing?
Okay.
I'll say, like...
I don't want, like...
I don't want the...
The...
UK secret society get to me.
But, like...
Hypothetically...
Isn't there a secret society...
In Oxford.
Where all the...
The big people...
Who may or may not...
Have been...
Prime ministers.
So...
Who...
May or may not...
Be prime ministers...
Uh...
Of...
Of the UK...
In secret...
In lot of secret societies.
In, like, you know...
Fraternities.
Some of the...
Ivy League...
The Ivy Leagues...
Of, like...
The UK.
You know...
May or may not...
Like...
Some schools...
Potentially...
You know...
Oxford.
Or, like...
Cambridge.
There was a...
Society there.
Like a...
Like...
It's sort of like a fraternity there.
That may or may not...
Hypothetically...
Where...
Some of the students there...
Did some really fucked up shit.
And they were...
Got there.
And then they may or may not...
Become prime minister.
Or holding very big positions of power.
But this random kid...
Skipped...
Sneaked out...
For an overnight field trip.
And then proceeds...
To get rejected...
In 26 other schools.
So what did he do?
What did he really do?
There was no way...
That...
It was just...
Sneaking out.
You know too much.
He didn't have enough power...
To cover it up.
Not good enough for hybrid.
Holy shit.
Next team.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The Ivy League equivalent...
Is Red Bricks...
Or just Oxbridge...
For the top tier.
Dubkeeper...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Apparently it's a thing to say...
Chat is Israel.
But it's actually...
Chat GPT.
Mr. Sen...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was nice knowing...
You don't keep lying.
I put that...
In Minecraft...
Sorry.
I forgot to add...
In Minecraft...
Obviously.
Minecraft...
Minecraft Oxford.
You know?
That's my favorite Minecraft server, guys.
That's...
That makes it...
Okay.
That makes it all right, chat.
Never mind.
She's cool.
Um, yeah.
Goddamn.
I love playing that Minecraft server where you can pretend to go to Minecraft Oxford in-game in Minecraft.
Uh, but anyway.
Yeah, so, like, they're talking about... Oh, my God.
This article is actually... I'm gonna link it to you guys so you can read, like, the quotes.
Because I was reading the quotes of it.
Of this article.
And it's...
It's actually... It's actually so interesting.
I was like, wait, that's what's going on in university right now?
But, like, I'll send you guys a link to it.
And, like, on Twitter.
And then you guys can, like, read through it.
It's actually super interesting.
I... Um... Because, like, you know... Um... I graduated university before ChatGPD was a thing.
So, like, obviously, I had to actually go to the library.
And...
I had to go to the library.
I had to go to Google Scholar.
Or, like, go to my library website to find books that was related to my topic.
And I had to actually look... Read the books.
Read.
Or, like, go to Google Scholar to find research articles.
And I couldn't do... At G... At Grok, please explain this.
Please.
I had to actually go to my library.
My university library.
And, like, take out the books related to the topic I wanted to do.
Like...
Uh...
Alright, C.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Give me money to my favorite consumers.
As usual.
Thank you for doing what you do, Doki.
You're so cool.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I really appreciate it.
Uh... AKB.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
College before AI.
Okay.
Unk.
Hey.
At least I can read a book.
At least I have to highlight.
I have to use highlighters.
And I can read a book.
I lost my... No, when you become a streamer...
When you become a streamer, you lost... You lose... You lose... You have to trade in, like, certain skill set.
It's like... It's like a deal with the devil at the crossroads.
But instead of that, it's like... You gotta trade in... You know how... It's like during, like...
When you're creating character.
And you have to, like, minus stats.
And then buff other stats and stuff.
I took away my reading stat.
And then put on, like...
Uh...
Put it on everything else.
I was like, I don't need that.
I reset my skill points.
Yeah.
I became a streamer.
Reset my skill points.
And was like...
And then, like, put it all on... On, like, other stuff.
I...
Intelligence in one.
And in everything... I min-max everything else.
I respect myself.
I...
More brain... Exactly.
More brain rot.
More charisma.
And then zero on intelligence.
We don't need magic.
We brute force our way in.
Like, 100 speech.
100... Speech 100.
That's right.
Ungabunga time.
Speech 100.
But yeah, that's an interesting article.
I just...
Just wanted to say that.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Um...
What was I gonna say?
How did I...
Oh my gosh.
Oh yeah.
Hey.
Oh wait.
Rice, thank you for the 10 gifted.
Ships, thank you.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Beeps, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I used floppy disk in college.
Don't remind me.
Oh yeah.
That must have been hell.
Because like, how many...
How much memory do you have in floppy disk anyway?
That's crazy to think about.
Because that shit can't store a lot of...
That shit can't store a lot of memory.
I remember like, if you show like, there was a video.
1.44 megabytes.
Jesus Christ.
I remember there was a video.
Where they showed like...
Um...
Gen Z.
Was it Gen Z or Gen...
Okay.
Gen A.
I think...
Okay.
What ages are in Gen A?
I remember if you showed like...
They showed like...
Um...
Like...
Stuff like...
Like stuff like floppy disk.
And...
Um...
What other stuff did they show them?
I remember floppy disk was one of them.
And they showed them that.
And they're like...
What do you think these things are?
And the kids were like...
Were like...
I don't know.
Gen A shown...
All the technology.
And they're like...
Oh...
What do you mean you don't know?
Oh yeah.
They're like...
It's a save icon.
Yeah.
That was it.
I remembered.
They were shown...
They were shown like the floppy disk.
And they're like...
That's the save icon.
So they don't know it was a floppy disk.
Wait.
Floppy disk...
Why is...
Okay.
Um...
Oh my god.
I wish I could find that video again.
That was so...
Uh...
Kids shown floppy disk.
Oh my god.
Kids...
Kids guess what I've...
Oh, is this video?
Oh wait.
I need to turn off my...
My music.
So I can see if it is.
It might be from outer space.
Excuse me?
The kid is like...
It might be from outer space.
What do you mean by that, child?
Why do you think it's from outer space?
Wait.
Where's my...
How...
When...
Wait.
Did the BGM stop?
When did the BGM stop?
When did the BGM...
Oh, silly child.
Unknown techno.
How long have I been ta...
A while ago?
Oh, guys.
How long have I been talking with no music, guys?
Um...
A while...
It last...
Whoops.
I think I accidentally closed...
I think I definitely...
Accidentally...
Uh...
Closed...
My BGM during all of this.
And I don't remember when.
I don't remember when I...
I closed my BGM.
I was just...
I was so...
Passionate about everything I was yapping about.
That I forgot...
There was no BGM.
Okay.
Kids...
Floppy...
Disc.
Oh my god.
It was such a funny video, too.
I wish I remember...
Uh...
I wish I remember, like...
What...
What video it was.
I was like...
It's like...
It might be from outer space.
CD player?
They actually call it a CD player?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I found this video and I thought that was funny.
This one.
There's no way.
These kids are not...
This was not even...
This was 2018.
They called it a fridge magnet?
A SIM card?
It's a CD?
Someone's like...
They're like...
Um...
How old was it?
And you're like...
Probably the 70s or 80s.
And then their kid was like...
The 40s?
Not the fridge magnet.
Bro, one of the child said...
Is this from the Victorian era?
Like...
Bro...
Someone told my guy...
The Victorian...
What?
Victorian era...
Floppy disk.
They're rage-baiting.
That child is rage-baiting me.
And I'm gonna take that bait.
Om, yum, yum, yum, yum.
I'm mad now.
That child is rage-baiting me.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Are we getting rage-baited by the child?
Also...
I realized, did I actually play any Twitter videos while I was trying to look through Twitter?
Was there like random sounds playing through?
Because like, I had... I didn't... Okay, no.
Okay, that's good.
Because like, um... I didn't realize... Okay, that's good though.
Yes?
Okay, I heard one random sound.
Okay, that's good.
Like...
From one thing... Okay, I don't know what that one thing was.
I don't know, but yes.
No, I just... Because I had like... I was looking through Twitter and some videos were playing.
So like, I don't... Because you know, like some videos...
Some videos would autoplay when you scroll down.
So like... That's why I was like, oh shit, it was...
It was a random boop sound.
Okay, that's good.
Because I didn't know what sound was playing.
Because I had my... When I talked... When I had BGM... I didn't... The reason why...
I have BGM playing...
The reason... I mean, the reason why I don't hear anything when I have BGM playing, And I don't know when the BGM stops.
Is because I actually mute on my end.
Of... Like, because I have a... You know, I have a mixer.
So I mute it on my end, because when I'm talking, I get very distracted hearing music while I talk.
So I don't realize when the BGM is muted because of that.
So like, I only turn it on so you guys can hear what I'm... you guys can have like little BGM going on.
But when I'm talking, I get distracted when I hear music playing, because it...
like, my train of thought gets distracted.
No, I muted it.
I muted it when I was looking through the videos and stuff.
So that's why I noticed really late that the BGM stopped anyway.
Mister Broken , thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I bet that kid doesn't even know when the Victoria era even happened.
Mister Stan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you. Welcome you've got mail.
You're the super chat butt, thank you.
Thank you.
Alright, let's think of the super chat.
There was one JP tweet I saw that said it looked like a vending machine.
And I've never looked at it same since.
Wait, does it actually?
Floppy disk.
I've never seen it like that.
Icon.
Oh, it does!
It looks like a clip art.
Wait, if you look at a clip art, it does look like it.
Fiction, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
I wish we had super chat reading segments at the end of your stream.
Like, if you do see this, will you play Gears of War?
I'm pretty sure I've talked about this before.
I'm pretty sure.
I said, like, that's, like, a game I've always wanted to try.
I remember talking about it before.
But thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
I've talked about how I've always wanted to try Gears of War.
Because, um...
Yeah.
And, um...
And that like, my dad loved Gears of War and I watched him play from 1 to 3.
Wait, did it go to 3?
I don't remember.
It's been a series.
So yeah.
Gears of War.
Yeah.
Yeah, and I watched him.
Oh wait, they have a 4.
I heard 4 was really bad.
Was 4 bad, right?
4 was really bad, right?
Or was it really good?
I remember it was... it went up to 5?
Wait, there's 5?
5 Gears of War?
4 doesn't exist.
But yeah, I remember talking about it before.
And the reason why I don't do super chat reading at the end of streams anymore is that...
The last couple of months, my... I've been... Also, within the last year, I've been really sick within the last year.
So I don't... I can't do super chat reading segments anymore.
Not anymore.
But like, I've been like, continuously sick.
And that's been like, really harsh on my throat a lot.
And so like, every time after the stream, I have to like, rest my voice.
And that's why we haven't had super chat readings for a long time.
But to make up for it, I usually try to...
Well, not for super chat readings.
But I usually chat a lot in the beginning of the stream.
And then like, go into it.
Because, you know, my throat is like, much stronger in the beginning of the stream.
And that lets me like, you know, talk to you guys for a while.
And...
And able to like, interact with you guys more before we get into the talk...
Into the game and stuff.
But I do... I remember saying it before, but...
One day, I'll be bringing it back.
When I'm... Because I'm still sick.
If you guys didn't know, I'm actually still sick.
Uh, I haven't fully recovered yet.
Um...
And...
I'm still trying to like, you know, recover from all of it.
Uh...
Because I remember when I brought...
I remember what one or...
For one week, I brought back super chat readings at the end of the stream.
For one week.
And then I got sick again.
Like...
Is that...
Is that fucked up?
I brought it back for one week and then I got sick again.
Yeah.
Was there one...
I don't even remember.
There was like one or two...
Maybe it was like one or two streams.
I did it for one or two streams and I got...
My body...
Immune system fucked up.
Um...
Let's see.
Uh...
Koyuki, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Kira, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
No, I think it's cause like...
Like, yeah, it's just, I think it's also stress.
I read that stress can make your immune system a lot weaker.
And obviously, I had a really, like, a year where I've been, like, really stressed out and lots of stuff has been happening.
So obviously, my immune system is a lot weaker.
It also didn't help that Canadian doctors were so hard to reach.
And for the longest time, I have a family doctor now, but I didn't go here for this last sickness just because it was more or less, it was like, not as bad, because, like, I didn't have, like, the coughing thing.
And that was the only reason why I didn't go to the doctor this time, because I didn't have the coughing thing going on, which is why, like...
But the last time I got really sick, I was coughing for a long time.
But yeah, I have a family doctor now, so everything is A-OK.
Hey, guys!
I'm gonna use that topic to end it, because speaking of throat health, I realized how long I've been streaming for, so I'm gonna call it for today, um, so I can finally rest my throat.
Um, because, uh, we had a lot of very long streams the last three days, so I think this is a good stopping point.
Uh, because I'm like, speaking of health, I guess it's time to rest.
Ha ha ha!
But, a lovely chat with all you guys.
I hope you guys have a good night, or a good morning, depending on where you guys are, or a good afternoon.
And we guys rest well.
Um, it's always great chatting with you guys.
Always have a fun time chatting with my dragoons.
And as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Don't worry, you are all forgiven for your sins today.
Um, anyway, bye-bye, everybody!
Bye!
Wait, I just, wait, I just read the super chat.
Many sins are not forgiven.
He's the only one.
Bye, guys!